[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
guten abend hinein an einem tag der die
frage stellt ist das ein ernst gemeintes
vermittlungsangebot oder nur perfide
kreml propaganda der russische gas
lobbyist gerhard schröder er war auch
mal bundeskanzler hat sich heute zu wort
gemeldet nach einem gespräch mit
wladimir putin in moskau und via
interview im stern und zwar mit einer
mischung aus konkreten vorschlägen
rechtfertigung der eigenen position und
setzten die so oder so ähnlich auch vom
russischen präsidenten selbst stammen
könnten und er hat im bizarren
nervenkrieg um eine reparierte turbine
seinem amtsnachfolger und spd
parteigenossen vorgeworfen die
unwahrheit zu sagen
der amtierende bundeskanzler stellt sich
heute vor eben diese turbine und warnt
davor russland auf den leim zu gehen
klaus brodbeck darum geht es gut 18
tonnen knapp 90.000 ps mülheim/ruhr
heute morgen die turbine deren fehlen
angeblich der grund für drastisch
reduzierte gaslieferungen aus russland
ist und auch darum geht es jedenfalls
dem kanzler gegenzuhalten gegen putins
propaganda deutschland blockiere den
weitertransport hin zur pipeline nord
stream 1 es gibt sie wirklich sind steht
hier sie es einsatzbereit und es ist
übrigens in der welt in der wir heute
leben etwas ganz einfaches sie zu
transportieren es muss nur einer sagen
bitte schickt sie los doch die turbine
steht und dient so weiter russlands
gaskonzern gazprom dem die pipeline
gehört als erklärung dafür dass sie
zwischen kaum noch gas nach westeuropa
gelangt technisch gesehen falsch in
portowaja stehen sechs solcher turbinen
plus zwei kleinere sie brauchen fünf von
diesen turbinen damit 100 prozent
leistung erzeugt wird davon läuft heute
eine wir können aus technischer sicht es
nicht nachvollziehen uns liegen keine
anderen informationen vor warum keine
betriebsbereitschaft da sein sollte
putins propaganda aber arbeitet
ausgerechnet heute ausgerechnet ihr
gerhard schröder per interview mit der
forderung putins neue pipeline nord
stream 2 trotz seines krieges in betrieb
zu nehmen wenn es wirklich eng wird gibt
es diese pipeline und mit beiden nord
stream-pipeline es gebe es kein
versorgungsproblem für die deutsche
industrie und die deutschen haushalte es
gibt genügend kapazitäten einen austria
1 da ist überhaupt keinen mangel an
möglichkeiten alle verträge die russland
geschlossen hat für ganz europa mit
hilfe dieser pipeline und der auch noch
in betrieb befindlichen ukraine pipeline
zu erfüllen schröder wäre kaum schröder
setzt er nicht noch einen drauf wieder
habe putin getroffen und nach dem genau
ein frachtschiff mit getreide die
ukraine verlassen konnte natürlich eine
botschaft die gute nachricht heißt der
kreml mit eine verhandlungslösung ein
erster erfolg ist das getreide abkommen
vielleicht kann man das langsam zu einem
waffenstillstand ausbauen
wir sehen leider keine
anzeichen davon dass putin wirklich
bereit scheint zu verhandeln das erste
zeichen wäre wenn putin zumindest jetzt
aufhört auf zivilisten zu schießen und
städte zu bombardieren das wäre eine
bessere botschaft als das was wir jetzt
von herrn schröder gehört haben richtig
es geht um mehr als nur um diese turbine
sogar das militär historiker an der uni
potsdam er befasst sich intensiv mit
diesem konflikt und auch mit möglichen
lösungen dafür guten abend und
willkommen zurück im heute-journal der
professor guten abend sie war ja gerhard
schröder hat gesagt die gute nachricht
heißt der kreml will eine
verhandlungslösung haben sie denn heute
von schroder etwas gehört von dem sie
sagen das wäre ein ansatz für
verhandlungen
nein es ist sicherlich auch falsches von
schröder von vornherein in bausch und
bogen zu verdammen
da gibt es ja auch reaktionen und muss
nur in ruhe sich dieses interview
durchlesen sehen was er sagt aber aus
meiner sicht ist da keine substanz drin
denn was schröder vorschlägt ist ja ihr
könnt man könnte sich einigen auf die
anerkennung der krim auf eine kantons
lösung im dom bars mit sprachpolitik und
auf nichtmitgliedschaft der nato der
ukraine das sind ja alles punkte die
vielleicht nicht de jure oder de facto
russland vor dem 24 februar vom westen
hätte bekommen können auch von der
ukraine und deswegen hätte putin diesen
krieg nicht führen müssen also ich sehe
in diesem interview eigentlich nur
nebelkerzen kein wirklich substanzielles
angebot sie haben auch im beitrag
erwähnt auch dieses rumgeeiert mit der
gas pipeline und den turbinen also
damals meiner sicht sagt schröder auch
die unwahrheit und eben dass putin eine
verhandlungslösung will wie schröders
gesagt hat sie haben es auch ein beitrag
gesagt das sehe ich so nicht schließlich
hat läuft ja noch vor einer woche gesagt
dass die ukraine sagen wird sich
ausgelöscht werden muss wir dürfen auch
nicht vergessen dass jeden tag in diesen
tagen vier bis fünftausend granaten von
der russischen at&t abgeschossen werden
ukrainische stellung das etwa 30
ukrainische soldaten jeden tag sterben
also nach verhandlungslösung sieht das
nicht aus da geben wir es vielleicht
nochmal ein bisschen durch ihr schröder
sagt niemand glaubt mehr dass ein
russischer präsident die krim wieder
aufgeben könnte da gibt es ja in der tat
eine ganze reihe von menschen die ihm da
zustimmen würden oder ja da würde ich
ihm auch zustimmen ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass ein russischer präsident
die krim wieder aufgeben würde ich sehe
auch nicht im gegenzug die militärische
fähigkeit der ukraine die krim
zurückzuerobern wir diskutieren jetzt in
der höchsten kreisen ob es der ukraine
vielleicht möglich sein könnte den
landkorridor zurück zur oberen aber da
gibt es ganz viele fragezeichen aber für
eine offensive richtung bremen nach
meiner einschätzung fehlen der ukraine
jede voraussetzung und dann müssen wir
eben unterscheiden was gibt es eine die
jure anerkennung die wird es nie geben
aber man kann sich eben auch mit der
normativen kraft des faktischen abfinden
wie ist ja der westen bei der annexion
der der krim aufgemacht hat und darauf
wird es sicherlich hinauslaufen für den
don was eine art status wie den von
schweizer kantonen auch dass eine idee
von gerhard schröder was sagen sie dazu
also das ist ja nun völlig abstrus es
meiner einschätzung also putin wird ja
ähnlich wie die grimm mit sicherheit
nicht dass
das gebiet wieder hergeben was man mit
den so viel blut seiner soldaten erobert
hat denken wir jetzt an an die
volksrepublik johann scalzo in das
wieder herzugeben und ursprünglich sah
es ja so vor dass man beide
volksrepublik ein teil der ukraine aber
mit mit einer sprachpolitik nach mit
einem eigenen sprachen und so also das
kann ich mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen
sondern das maximale ziel was ich für
realistisch halte aber nach mir geht es
da nicht sondern es ist sagte der
ukraine russlands ist das war vielleicht
ein status quo ante erreicht also die
linie die es am 24 februar gab aber
selbst das wäre für die ukraine ich
glaube ich ein großer erfolg und ich
sehe überhaupt nicht dass putin bereit
wäre sowas zu akzeptieren dann gehen wir
vielleicht ein bisschen weg von gerhard
schröder es ist ja generell so dass sich
viele menschen tatsächlich fragen auch
hier bei uns in deutschland wie lange
dieser krieg noch dauert ist denn eine
verhandlungslösung aus ihrer sicht
überhaupt realistisch auf absehbare zeit
oder vielleicht anders gefragt was muss
denn passieren damit eine
verhandlungslösung realistisch sein
könnte naja also kriege werden begonnen
weil die staaten meinen einem gegner mit
militärischen mitteln den willen
aufzuzwingen und kriege werden beendet
weil entweder das gelingt das mit
militärischen mitteln den willen
aufzwingen oder
weil man merkt man kommt damit nicht so
recht weiter
die eigenen kräfte gehen aus und dann
muss sich weil das militär nicht
ausreicht auf einen kompromiss einlassen
so und ich sehe genau diesen zwang zur
zeit nicht weder auf seiten der ukraine
noch auf seiten russlands ich glaube
nicht dass die ukraine glaubt dass sie
am ende ihrer militärischen
möglichkeiten ist ich sehe die hoffnung
beim ukrainischen generalstab zumindest
die landbrücke zurückzuerobern
also südlich sapporo und so weiter und
ich glaube dass putin zumindest aus
seiner logik der meinung ist er hat noch
nicht alle militärischen karten
ausgespielt das heißt nicht dass es nie
zu einer kompromisslösung kommen wird
aber ich glaube nicht jetzt da dran wenn
wir in einem jahr wieder reden ist die
lage vielleicht eine andere aber ich
würde es sehr unwahrscheinlich halten
wenn im verlauf dieses jahres man
wirklich einen stabilen waffenstillstand
eine irgendwie eine stabile
kompromisslösung erreichen würden ganz
kurz noch herr professor wenn ich sie
darum bitten darf was ist denn generell
von verhandlungen von vereinbarungen zu
halten mit vladimir putin können dass
nach all dem was wir jetzt erlebt haben
verträge seien auf die man sich dann
auch verlassen kann verlassen kann man
sich bestimmt nicht darauf aber es ist
immer noch besser als nichts das sehen
wir jetzt mit dem getreide verhandlungen
ja es ist nur ein schiff jetzt müssen
wir abwarten was weiterkommt aber auch
das ist besser als nichts aus ich würde
immer argumentieren wir müssen die
diplomatie mit einbeziehen müssen alles
probieren was möglich ist aber wirklich
darauf vertrauen dass solche verträge
halten das können wir natürlich nicht
professor weizel uni potsdam heute abend
weder herzlichen dank für ihre analyse
sehr gerne
ja weil auf russische energie kein
verlass mehr ist drängt die frage was
nun die berliner ampelkoalition hat sich
ziemlich verkeilt bei der suche nach
einer antwort da kommt von unseren
nachbarn in belgien die nachricht der
atomausstieg dort wird verschoben nicht
nur um ein paar monate sondern gleich um
ein jahrzehnt
bemerkenswert ist das auch deshalb weil
in der belgischen regierung die grünen
mit an der macht sind und weil die
belgischen reaktoren in der
vergangenheit mehrfach durch mängel
aufgefallen sind florian
mittwoch es ist markttag in eine stunde
östlich von brüssel sie schauen nach
allem was sie so brauchen und kaum auf
diesen reaktor der nur wenige meter
entfernt über dem städtchen thront und
mit dem sie wohl länger leben müssen als
gedacht deutlich länger
es macht mir grosse angst weil es so nah
an den menschen ist warum macht man das
nicht wenigstens weit weg von
wohngebieten ist capitals jungs hier
aber wenn wir nicht mit der atomkraft
weitermachen dann werden wir bald nicht
ausreichend strom haben wenn man etwas
gleichwertiges hätte ohne radioaktives
risiko gut aber für den moment haben wir
einfach nichts wonach hier in belgien
kommen noch 40 prozent des stroms aus
der atomkraft deutlich mehr als aus
erneuerbaren energien oder gas
2025 aber sollte mit der kernenergie
schluss sein das war seit langem der
plan doch dann kamen der krieg gegen die
ukraine der anstieg der energiepreise
die wende von den sieben reaktoren will
belgien nur noch fünf abschalten 2
hingegen werden verlängert um gleich
zehn jahre bis 2035 es ist ausgerechnet
eine grüne energie ministerin die das
nun umsetzen und verkaufen muss
unserer wirtschaft unseren unternehmen
aber auch unseren bürgern nun sicherheit
und ruhe
es ist ein kompromiss einer mit dem sie
es am ende keinen recht macht weder der
eigenen basis noch den mitregierenden
liberalen
unser meile ist sehr klar dass wir
weiter gehen als nur zwei atomkraftwerke
zu verlängern aus einem einfachen grund
es geht hier von beginn an um
klimaschutz kernenergie stößt doch kein
co2 aus
das ist natürlich ein worst case
szenario eine grüne ministerin die sich
so unter druck gesetzt fühlt oder
eingeschüchtert dass sie einem
schlechten vorschlag zustimmen muss ein
oder zwei reaktoren bringen nicht viel
für die energiesicherheit aber sie
bringen so viele technische probleme
oder tweets so many tactical problems
tier aus belgien das ist nämlich auch
eine chiffre für pannen für
sicherheitsprobleme zwar sollen nun der
jüngste der drei reaktoren weiterlaufen
aber auch der ist bald 40 jahre alt was
sie nicht nur im benachbarten aachen
beunruhigt radioaktivität kennt keine
grenzen von daher gibt es auch gespräche
mit dem ziel auch bei gehen darin zu
unterstützen die entscheidung zu
verkürzen belgien ändert den kurs in der
atompolitik fragt sich was das
kurzfristig bringt im nächsten winter
laufen die meiler ohnehin noch und bevor
ihre laufzeit danach verlängert werden
kann müssen sie erst einmal kosten
billig saniert werden
die atomkraft spielt auch eine wichtige
rolle in der ukraine und sie führt
aktuell im krieg zu großer besorgnis
damit beginnst du jetzt alarm es geht um
das größte atomkraftwerk europas und der
chef der internationalen
atomenergiebehörde hat sich sehr besorgt
über die situation des kraftwerks im
ukrainischen sapori china geäußert seit
märz ist die anlage von russischen
truppen besetzt und die lage sei sehr
fragil sagte grossi bei einer
pressekonferenz immer wieder gebe es
berichte über kampfhandlungen rund um
das kraftwerk und eine inspektion durch
die internationale atomenergiebehörde
sei dringend erforderlich
nach monatelanger russischer blockade
hat es das erste schiff mit ukrainischen
getreide aus dem schwarzen meer
geschafft die ladung des frachters ra
sony wurde zuvor in istanbul von
internationalen experten kontrolliert
und anschließend freigegeben nun kann
das schiff die ladung von über 26.000
tonnen getreide in den libanon bringen
in den kommenden tagen sollen weitere
schiffe aus ukrainischen hessen folgen
mehrere monate lang lagen die
atomgespräche mit iran auf eis nun haben
die usa und iran eine fortsetzung
angekündigt und wollen sich morgen mit
weiteren unterhändlern in wien treffen
dabei geht es um eine wiederbelebung des
internationalen atom abkommens mit dem
ziel dass iran keine atomwaffen
herstellt ex-us-präsident trump hatte
das abkommen 2018 gekündigt
fast 31 jahre nach einem brandanschlag
auf eine asylbewerberunterkunft in
saarlouis hat die bundesanwaltschaft
anklage gegen einen rechtsextremisten
erhoben sie wirft dem mutmaßlichen täter
mord versuchten mord in 20 fällen sowie
brandstiftung mit todesfolge und
versuchter todesfolge vor bei dem
anschlag im september 1991 war ein 27
jähriger mann aus ghana gestorben der
tatverdächtige sitzt seit april in
untersuchungshaft der staatsschutzsenat
des oberlandesgerichts koblenz muss nun
entscheiden ob es zu einem prozess kommt
es gibt länder da können und wollen sich
die menschen nur noch dunkel erinnern
corona was war das gleich es gibt länder
die haben nach wie vor strikte
vorschriften
diese enorme bandbreite erleben wir ja
auch hier immer wieder die einen haben
für sich persönlich mit allen coroner
regeln abgeschlossen die anderen halten
jedes mal den atem an wenn jemand im zug
die maske ab setzt das thema polarisiert
nach wie vor so gesehen keine
überraschung dass bei der frage mit
welchen gesetzen deutschland in den
corona herbst gehen soll ein kompromiss
heraus gekommen ist zwischen unablässig
warnendem gesundheitsminister und
demonstrativ gelassenem justizminister
interessant auch wie sie ihren
infektionsschutz entwurf heute
vorgestellt haben der eine von seinem
dienstsitz aus der andere am urlaubsort
andrea maurer hat mir sie haben lange
gerungen der gesundheitsminister und der
justizminister leicht war es nicht es
ist kein geheimnis dass lauterbach gerne
früher aktiv geworden wäre man habe sich
nicht von aktionismus treiben lassen
sagt buschmann und lässt sich heute wie
zum beweis nur aus dem urlaub zu
schalten
alle diese dinge die man unter dem
begriff lockdown versteht
ausgangssperren betriebsschließung
schulschließung all diese dinge halten
wir nicht mehr für angemessen
für den dritten herbst der pandemie soll
laut entwurf ein mehrstufiges
schutzkonzept gelten zentrales
instrument die maske bundesweit masken
pflicht im luft und fernverkehr masken
und testpflicht in krankenhäusern und
pflegeheimen
die länder wiederum können optional
entscheiden über masken pflicht in
öffentlichen innenräumen masken pflicht
den schulen aber nur ab der fünften
klasse in restaurants theatern oder
fitnessstudios sind ausnahmen von der
masten pflicht für getestete frisch
geimpfte und frisch genesene möglich
grenzwerte bestimmt nicht mehr der bund
sondern die länder sie können je nach
lage etwa die masken pflicht noch
verschärfen kritik aus bayern also gut
gemeint ist noch lange nicht gut gemacht
da sind noch viele viele fragen die es
zu klären gilt im vollzug ich hätte mir
gewünscht dass es einfacher ist auch für
den bürger tatsächlich leichter
erkenntlich was wir jetzt vor haben und
was wir machen wollen dass die
bestimmung der parameter auch klar ist
wann sind welche maßnahmen zu treffen da
sind viele fragen drin die handwerklich
auch noch geklärt werden müssen und das
erwarte ich jetzt vom bund für den
herbst kündigt der
bundesgesundheitsminister vier neue
impfstoffe an und definiert frisch
geimpft als einlass kriterium heute so
mindestens die dritte impfung höchstens
drei monate alt führte impfung also
irgendwann notwendig aber dann wenn man
jetzt quasi diese impfung nutzen will um
beispielsweise in restaurants oder in
cafés bars ranzukommen
im herbst werden ab dem 1 diese regelung
geht dann macht es natürlich sinn die
neuen impfstoffe noch abzuwarten wenn es
aber jetzt jemand ist der also hohes
risiko hat wenn er erkrankt auch schwer
zu erkranken würde ich auf keinen fall
abwarten der druck zu einer aktuellen
impfung soll im herbst also nochmal
erhöht werden am 24 august will das
kabinett die änderungen auf den
gesetzgebungs weg bringen von oktober
bis ostern sollen die neuregelungen
gelten
china kann die politiker der welt nicht
daran hindern taiwan zu besuchen hat
nancy pelosi gesagt als sprecherin des
repräsentantenhauses die nummer 3 der
amerikanischen politik und diesen satz
eindrucksvoll selbst unter beweis
gestellt ihr besuch in taiwan war ein
zeichen der solidarität mit der insel
mit ihren menschen der lebendigen
demokratie dort der tatsache dass man
seine meinung sagen darf ein zeichen
dass die usa an der seite taiwans stehen
gegen die offenen drohungen aus peking
einerseits andererseits war der besuch
auch ein drahtseilakt weil chinas
machthaber sich herausgefordert fühlt
und wütend reagiert die gefahr einer
unkontrollierten eskalation kann auch
nancy pelosi nicht abschätzen ulf röller
berichtet fangen wir das stück einmal
anders an china liefert nicht mehr den
haar schwanz fisch nach taiwan er steht
auf der sanktionsliste wie zitrusfrüchte
liebe und wut gehen bei peking durch den
magen im fernsehen schwören die
staatsmedien das volk auf eine krise ein
die chinesische volksarmee sagte
sprecher ist in höchster
alarmbereitschaft
dieses treffen wollte china unbedingt
verhindern die vorsitzende des us
repräsentantenhauses nancy pelosi
begrüßt von der taiwanesischen
präsidentin sein wenn die botschaft an
peking die usa werden taiwans
eigenständigkeit verteidigen pelosi weiß
um die schlagkraft ihrer worte weiß dass
sie die region erschüttern werden wir
fühlen uns taiwans sicherheit
verpflichtet und wir wollen dass sich
das land selbst verteidigen kann es geht
um demokratie und um freiheit die taiwan
so vorbildlich repräsentieren
während polos sie diese worte spricht
hat china schon seit stunden seine
truppen in marsch gesetzt
die machthaber haben befohlen sich
militärmanöver um taiwan abzuhalten die
menschen dort befürchten dass china den
luftraum und die seewege der insel
blockiert denn mit scharfer munition übt
die chinesische gruppe peking will eine
vereinigung mit taiwan notfalls mit
militärischer gewalt erreichen
taiwan ist nie ein eigenständiges land
gewesen historisch gesprochen es ist
eine provinz der volksrepublik china
die nationale propaganda läuft auf
hochtouren china will mit den manövern
stärke demonstrieren aber vielen
chinesen im netz ist das zu wenig sie
fordern taiwan anzugreifen pelosis
besuch empfinden sie als ohrfeige
eigenwilliger protest macht sich in den
sozialen medien breit
präsident steht unter druck nicht
schwach vor seinem volk dazu stehen aber
er wird es wohl nicht auf einem
militärischen konflikt ankommen lassen
das ist für sie den ping vor allen
dingen eine demonstration der stärke
einen demonstrationen der bilder für das
eigene publikum für die eigenen
politischen eliten ich glaube
kurzfristig sieht er dass china nicht in
der lage ist ohne existenzielle risiken
so ein militärkonflikt wirklich zu
gewinnen an chinas strand rund 160
kilometer entfernt von taiwans küste
rollen demonstrativ die panzer peking
inszeniert bisher nur eine schlacht der
bilder die aber ängstigt die region
die menschen in badehose schon zu taiwan
hat verglichen mit seiner größe eine
außerordentliche bedeutung für die welt
auch das wird jetzt wieder klar hanna
und dabei geht es um ziemlich kleine
teile ohne die weltweit so gut wie gar
nichts mehr geht taiwan ist marktführer
bei halbleitern und die stecken quasi
überall drin vom smartphone bis zur
industrieanlage die abhängigkeit von der
insel ist also groß stefanie bareth in
frankfurt welche rolle spielt das in
diesem konflikt ja eine ganz zentrale
rolle tatsächlich sehen strategen in
taiwans halbleiter dominanz sogar seine
wichtigste lebensversicherung quasi
einen schutzschild aus silizium der
nicht nur china und die usa die gesamte
weltwirtschaft ist abhängig von taiwans
modernen halbleitern mit einem globalen
markt an teil von 64 prozent liegt das
land bei auftragsfertigungen weit vor
südkorea und china wie kein zweites land
hat taiwan bereits vor 40 jahren auf
halbleiter gesetzt und mit staatlichen
milliarden seinen globalen chip champion
tsmc aufgebaut kaum jemand kennt diesen
namen aber seine chips stecken einfach
überall drin in hochkomplexen maschinen
der luft und raumfahrt ebenso wie in
einfachen steuerungselementen von autos
und kühlschränken und auf diese
halbleiter ist nicht nur der westen
angewiesen sie sind auch immens wichtig
für die modernisierung chinas stellen
sogar das bedeutendste import gut
überhaupt da sollten sich die usa nun
mehr und mehr von china abgrenzen
fürchtet die volksrepublik den zugriff
auf taiwans halbleiter zu verlieren das
mag die militärischen muskelspiele
erklären immerhin blieb eine größere
konfrontation über nacht aus dass sorgte
heute auch international für
erleichterung an den finanzmärkten
der dax beendete den handel mit einem
plus von einem prozent anleger bleiben
aber vor dem hintergrund der spannungen
durchaus nervös danke stefanie für diese
einschätzungen
nach den warnstreiks des lufthansa
bodenpersonals haben die airline und die
gewerkschaft verdi heute ihre
tarifverhandlungen fortgesetzt verdi
fordert 9,5 prozent mehr lohn für die
rund 20.000 beschäftigten gespräche sind
auf zwei tage angesetzt gibt es keine
einigung drohen neue streiks vergangenen
mittwoch waren wegen der
arbeitsniederlegung fast alle lufthansa
flüge ausgefallen
und jetzt die lottozahlen von diesem
mittwoch die lauten 5 11 13 21 40 43
superzahl 9 alle angaben wie immer ohne
gewähr
viel glück das war unsere welt an diesem
mittwoch danke für ihr interesse und
jürgen sind sehen wir uns morgen wieder
[Musik]
schön gedacht und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter das muster für die
hitzewellen das wiederholt sich so auch
dieser tage kommt die hitze von spanien
über frankreich nach deutschland und hat
morgen ihren höhepunkt die kaltfront die
uns erreicht verdrängt diese hitze dann
nach südosten das ganze sieht dann
folgendermaßen aus südwestlichen
richtungen kommt dieser hitze blase und
wird dann allmählich nach süd osten
abgedrängt in der kommenden nacht ist
kaum etwas los die sterne funkeln vom
himmel bei temperaturen die teilweise
kaum unter die 20 grad marke fallen vor
allem in den städten ist es sehr warm
die hitzebelastung ist groß im südosten
noch am kühlsten mit 14 grad morgen an
viel sonnenschein und dann zum
nachmittag und in den abendstunden kommt
von nordwesten schauer und gewitter auf
und das bei höchst